[MUSIC PLAYING]
SHAWN: Hi, my name is Shawn.
Today I'd like to talk about
how WebCore, Blink, and
WebKit, how we do compositing
in WebKit.
So the way Chromium works,
we actually have several
different pieces that
fit together.
Blink is basically our
rendering engine.
We forked from WebKit
recently.
And what happens is, Blink as
a rendering engine uses a
compositor.
The compositor is implemented
in Chromium.
What I'd like to talk about
today is how Blink actually
chooses what gets composited.
What does compositing
really mean?
And these sorts of
basic concepts.
And I will also get into bits
of implementation detail and
code pads for those who are
interested at the end.
So yeah, let's get started.
And maybe you can go
to the slides now.
OK so what you're seeing here is
imagine maybe this is some
sort of HTML page.
These boxes could be considered
as divs, and the
question here is as we see this
animation happening on
the yellow div, what actually
needs to be
rerendered or repainted?
If we assume the traditional
rendering model where we have
software just going pixel by
pixel and figuring out what
the color of each pixel is, and
we only have one set of
pixels to represent the final
output image, the answer would
be portions of all
four layers.
Now, yeah, if we're smart enough
in WebKit or in Blink,
we could say, yes, there's
actually only a portion of the
actual full size image that
needs to be rerendered.
So I'll look again.
Yeah, only this portion needs
to be rerendered.
But still all four layers really
do need to be repainted
in order to get that
scene correct.
So what that means is, and by
the way, the fourth layer here
is the gray background.
So what that really means is as
this yellow div, say as it
spins around, for example, it
will actually expose parts of
the gray element
underneath it.
And that gray really does need
to be repainted just as much
as the yellow layer actually
needs to be repainted as well.
The same would be true for the
blue layer underneath the
yellow one and even, possibly,
unless we're very clever,
which we're actually not in
Blink we would also actually
have to repaint portions of this
red layer on top of the
yellow layer.
One thing to point out is that
computing these pixels, the
value, the color
of these pixels
actually gets pretty expensive.
It's surprisingly complicated.
Not only do we have things like
background colors, we
also have borders.
The borders could be curved.
We need anti-aliasing
for the borders.
Then we need to support things
like blending for
transparency.
Text rendering, anti-alias text
rendering, is a whole
other beast.
All of these things add up and
it becomes quite expensive to
figure out what the color of
each pixel is to actually
render a page.
Another example here is imagine
if we have a web page
that we want to scroll.
I wasn't able to get this to
animate or interact on the
presentation, but if you just
imagine this blue layer here
scrolling up and down.
What that really means is that
we actually have to repaint,
rerender every pixel,
almost every pixel
on this entire view.
And, again, that's
very expensive.
Now, you might be asking, well
couldn't we just recognize
that this layer is shifting and
instead of rerendering and
recomputing every pixel
maybe we can just
shift that pixel up.
And that is a very
good observation.
In fact, that's exactly what we
would use compositing for.
And, in particular, what we
would need is not just one
backing store, not just one
buffer of pixels, but we
actually need multiple buffers
of pixels so that we could
store this blue layer
in a separate layer,
in a separate buffer.
And then when we need to, we can
just copy it over to the
final output image in
a shifted position.
So that's basically what
compositing is.
It's the use of multiple backing
stores to cache and
group chunks of the
render tree.
So how does this help us?
Well, like I just said,
it can help us to
avoid unnecessary repaints.
We don't have to figure out what
the color of every pixel
is every time we need
to change something.
Instead, we can just cache
that and redraw it.
It's a little bit of a
terminology thing.
Repainting, in our case, would
mean that we really have to
rerender every pixel and figure
out what color it is.
Redrawing would be when we
already know the color of the
pixel and we just need to
display it to the screen.
So, again, repainting would
be considered very costly.
Redrawing is very cheap.
So, for example, in this
animation that you had seen
already, if we had a layer for
the yellow that was a separate
backing store.
If we had a separate backing
store for the red layer.
These two layers, both, so
that we could put the red
layer on top of yellow, and
the yellow on top of
everything else, then we would
actually not need to repaint
anything as that example
animates.
So other benefits of
compositing, it also makes
some things practical
that otherwise just
wouldn't really work.
Especially if we use hardware
accelerated compositing.
In particular, things like
WebGL or hardware video
decoding they are just
best done on the GPU.
And having to read back from the
GPU to be able to render a
final output image can get
pretty costly and performance
would just go out the window.
So being able to composite what
we render on WebGL or
what we decode from hardware
video at the same time as
compositing both on the GPU,
it's a great enabler to make
things like WebGL and hardware
video decoding possible.
So what really needs to be
done when we talk about
compositing?
It's really just three
basic tasks.
Three straightforward tasks.
One, we need to figure out what
we would like to put in a
separate backing store.
And I tend to call these
composited layers as opposed
to what WebCore rendering
layers.
We also need to figure out what
the contents of those
layers will be, render
the pixels.
And that's what we're
calling painting.
And we also need to finally draw
the composited layers in
order to render the
final webpage.
So step three is what the
compositor's job is.
And we actually won't be
focusing on how the compositor
actually works in Chromium, but
for this talk what I would
like to talk about is just a
small little micro slice of
things where we actually
figure out what gets
composited and why.
And in order to explain things
clearly I will also have to
talk a little bit about how
things are painted.
So in case you're interested in
the bigger picture and how
things fit together, there's
several other talks and links.
These slides will be available
on dev.Chromium.org under the
Tech Talks Slides link.
And these talks and these docs
are also available there.
So Eric Seidel gave to talk a
while ago about WebCore's guts
and how rendering works, even
the software world with
respect to things like taking
the HTML that you provide and
converting it from a DOM tree
to a rendering tree.
That's what Eric's
talk is about.
Brett Wilson also gave a talk
on some other details of how
painting works.
In particular, the API is used
to actually do painting.
Chromium's compositor has
quite a few docs.
This link is one that I think
is the overall one.
Also available on
dev.chromium.org.
And what I would do in this talk
is bridge the gap between
once we have a tree of render
layers that we can actually
render to the screen, how we
go from there to a tree of
composited layers that the
compositor knows how to draw.
And it actually is pretty
insightful for web developers
to have this in mind.
Maybe it's not necessarily
appropriate to develop your
web to tailor to compositing,
but it is very appropriate to
be aware of these issues when
you think about how you want
to design your page.
So in order to describe why we
would choose things to become
composited and how we do that,
let's really, really quickly
cover some CSS details.
So you might already know
about positioning.
Elements can be either in what's
called normal flow
where layout really does
position them automatically,
and elements interact with each
other when they're all in
normal flow.
Relative position you can
specify on elements.
It keeps your elements in a
normal flow, but it allows you
to position the element with
respect to where it would've
been in normal flow.
Absolute positioned elements and
fixed position elements,
on the other hand, actually are
taken out of normal flow.
So when this layout is computed
for normal flow
elements, absolute position
elements and fixed position
elements actually do not affect
that part of the layout.
And this allows you to actually
position with a bit
more control your elements.
So absolute positioned elements
would be positioned
with respect to a containing
block.
Fixed positioned elements would
typically be positioned
with respect to a viewport.
So from there CSS also has
this concept of a Z-index
which allows you to control the
ordering of how elements
are layered on top
of each other.
And this is the beginnings of
where compositing becomes
interesting.
Because in order to render
things that are stacked on top
of each other, and they may be
dynamically changing, they may
have animations.
The Z-index is what causes
that, typically.
And so the compositor really
relies on Z-index
a lot of the time.
Yes, so one important thing to
note is that if we have a
positioned element that also has
a Z-index according to the
CSS spec, that would be defined
as a stacking context.
So what is the stacking
context?
A stacking context, it's a very
nice concept, actually.
And I think it actually gets
overlooked quite a lot from a
web developer's perspective.
A stacking context is a way to
flatten a group of layers into
a single conceptual layer from
outside of the subtree.
So here is an example where I
have four different stacking
contexts in this example.
The fourth, the smaller stacking
context over here, is
actually a stacking
context within the
green stacking context.
There's no way to
indicate that.
I'm just telling you that that's
what I had intended
when making this figure.
And you'll see that, OK, so a
negative Z-index renders below
a 0 is Z-index value, which
renders below a
Z-index value of 1.
And you note that even though I
have large Z-indexes here in
the blue and also in yellow
layers here, these are
actually inside of a stacking
context which means that they
are flattened to their stacking
context before they
are rendered with respect
to everything
else in the DOM tree.
So, for example, if we made
the Z-index 2 on this blue
stacking context, it suddenly
is designated as the one on
top of everything else, and
that's what you would see.
So the previous example the
Z-index was 0 making it 2
would actually render
everything on top.
So the way to interpret stacking
contexts is they're
really flattening the
element's subtree.
So it forms a nice isolation
between what's in the subtree
of a stacking context and what's
outside of the subtree.
Inside of the subtree of this
stacking context, all layers
think that they have their own
isolated universe without
knowing about anything else.
Outside of the stacking context,
that stacking context
is then just treated like a
normal conceptual layer.
Atomic, that's the key word.
An atomic conceptual layer.
So at the end of the day, what
CSS Spec found that is that
this is a very nice place to
define the order of how we're
supposed to paint things when
you give us a web page.
And, yes, actually CSS spec
does specify paint order.
It's a little bit complicated,
you can see the full details
in section 9.9 in Appendix
E of the spec.
You can just find
it on Google.
But the basic idea is that first
we paint backgrounds and
borders for a given element.
And then we paint the negative
Z-index children.
Then, whatever contents of the
layers itself or any other
normal flow elements that are
part of this layers subtree
get painted.
After that we do absolute
position and
positive Z-index children.
So what this means is that we're
actually creating a tree
that is not quite corresponding
to the DOM tree.
There's cases where you can
have an element in the DOM
tree that may appear first in
the list of children, but if
you put the [? Craig ?]
Z-index on it, it may have
to paint last on top of
everything else.
Another thing would be that
depending on how the tree is
structured, you may even get,
what you had as parent-child
pairs in the DOM, might be more
appropriate as siblings
when we talk about the order
in which they paint.
And that's how things are
implemented in Blink.
Where we actually take render
layers as the data structure
and instead of using the tree of
render layers that coarsely
approximates the DOM, instead
we actually collect layers
into a different tree.
And I'll call that the paint
order entry in this case.
But otherwise, it implements
equivalently the same paint
order as the CSS spec.
So given that, how do we choose
to composite layers?
Which layers do we choose
to be composited?
Well we would choose composited
layers based on
when it benefits us or when
we really need to.
So cases where it benefits us
is if we have transparency.
Maybe we have a transform that
is just easier to apply by
feeding transform matrix
to the GPU.
There may be some filters
like blur.
Reflections where it's nice to
be able to just have that
chunk of layers or that subtree
of layers cached
before we actually reflect it.
It's a good opportunity to make
it a composited layer so
that all we have to do instead
of rerendering it twice is
just redraw this same
pixels reflected.
Scrolling is another example
where instead of having to
repaint we can just put
everything into a layer and
shift the layer and give the
wonderful allusion of scrolling.
Fixed-position elements that
need to stay fixed even though
things underneath it may change
is another example
where if we just composite this
fixed-position element we
don't have to redraw it
every time things
underneath it changed.
And then, of course, as I said
before things, like WebGL or
hardware video coding are also
nice to make composited layers
just so that we can take
advantage of not having to
read them back into
software before we
actually render them.
There's also a necessary evil of
having to deal with when we
really need to composite.
Now part of this is, I have to
admit, how WebCore and Blink
are actually implemented.
How the compositing is
actually implemented?
But for the foreseeable future
this is going to be the way
things are.
And these are realities
we have to live with.
If there's a layer that overlaps
another composited
layer, and I'll show an example
of this in a second,
then we actually have to make
that composited as well.
Another issue is that if there's
some sort of CSS
property that needs to be
propagated down to composited
layers, for example, opacity,
or maybe some transform is
inherited by an ancestor.
Those are cases where the
parent that has that
information needs to be
composited just for the sake
of having that information in
the composited tree as well as
in the render tree.
So that all the composited
layers actually get the
information that they need.
So here's an example
of overlap.
Imagine we have one backing
store in our webpage.
If that's all we had.
And this backing store I'm just
representing that by a
red rectangle here.
If that's all we had, then we
would repaint all of these
pixels in one backing
store and be
done with it, no problem.
But suppose we thought we would
benefit for some reason
from making this blue layer a
separately composited layer.
So what we would have is backing
store one would draw
underneath backing store two.
Or, actually, it might be more
appropriate to say backing
store two, depending on how we
talk about things, would
actually redraw itself into
backing store one.
If we do that the green element
that we had intended
to be on top would not be on
top because we're painting
this into backing store one.
This is the case where overlap
requires us to create another
composited layer so that the
green element can actually
draw on top of what we thought
we would like composite, which
was the blue layer.
So it's interesting that
this comes up.
In the real world this can
cause an explosion of the
number of composited layers,
which can drain GP resources
quite badly.
So this is something
to be aware of.
In general, personally, I
haven't found any explosion of
layer counts too badly
in the real world.
But it's something
to be aware of.
If you're making a very
complicated web app that
things that overlap something
that might get composited will
probably also have to
get composited.
So there are some other cases
where overlap becomes
interesting.
Animations, in particular, is an
interesting one where it's
actually not really practical
to predict what will overlap
an animated layer at
any given time.
So instead we just assume that
everything on top is going to
overlap, even if it doesn't.
And I'll actually show
an example of
that in just a second.
So that's another interesting
thing to be aware of is that
when you have animations you
might actually see lots of
layers suddenly pop up,
composited layers, pop up on
your page simply because
the animation
is underneath things.
And by bringing animation on top
you might be able to avoid
unnecessarily causing
things to be
composited in your webpage.
This third point is also very
interesting to note.
This is where stacking contexts
actually become very useful.
Because if you have children
that are inside of a second
context, you know that they
are treated as atomic with
respect to everything else
outside of that subtree.
And what that allows you to
do then, is if you made a
stacking context out of the
subtree of your DOM, you can
feel a little bit more
comfortable that you won't
have an explosion of composited
layers inside of
that subtree.
Instead, the compositor will
recognize, OK, this is
stacking context.
I can make one composited
layer for this
entire stacking context.
And I don't need to check if
everything else overlaps
inside of the subtree if it
overlaps other content.
So basically what we do then
in Blink is we iterate over
this paint order tree,
recursively.
And we ask, does this layer
need compositing?
Would we benefit from it?
And then we also ask, now that
we've chosen composited layers
for the subtree, once we
bubble back up from the
recursion we have to ask, well,
is there some reason
that maybe we ought to composite
this parent as well?
For example, overlap.
Or if something in the subtree
became composited that needs
some properties like transform
or opacity.
And at the end, once we've
decided if something change
its state whether a subtree
needs to be composited or not
composited we also have
to issue that
it needs to be repainted.
OK, let's go to some demos.
See some examples of this
stuff in action.
If you'd like to try this on
your own, there's probably
four essential--
or maybe these first three are
the most essential command
line flags that you'd
like to use.
First, force-compositing mode.
Just in case.
For example, if you're on
Linux or if you're in a
situation where it seems like
you might be running software
mode instead, force-compositing
mode will
ensure that you're actually
using accelerated compositing
on all your pages, even if they
didn't really require it.
So just in case you actually
don't see what you expect, try
force-compositing mode.
Show composited layer
borders is probably
the most useful one.
This allows you to visualize
orange and some other color
borders around layers that
become composited.
And it's very insightful.
Show paint rects is also
very valuable.
What this shows is regions of
the page and regions of
various layers that actually
needed to be repainted.
That implies that we had to do
very expensive paint process
to figure out the pixels
of that region.
And generally what you would
like to do to get really
performant web apps is minimize
the amount of paint
rects that you see if you
were to visualize this.
Another one that we have, it's
not really as useful, but it
is still there, is show
property change recs.
What you'll see here is these
will be layers that, for
example, have an animation
where, yes, they did not need
repainting, but they had some
property that changed on them
that does require them
to be redrawn.
If you see these sorts of recs
then chances are you're in a
good state because you didn't
need to repaint.
But rather, you can just
quickly redraw them.
So, for example, in animation
you might actually see that.
So yeah let's run some demos
and see how this looks.
So I have a script of my
own called runtest.
This is basically just my way
of running Chrome from the
command line.
I have a command line [? rx ?]
show composite layer borders.
Let's see, we can go to Poster
Circle is it as one of the
standard examples for
looking at 3D CSS.
And what you see here
is orange borders.
This is the composited layer
borders flag showing you that
all of these layers here that
are being animated in 3D,
they're getting composited so
that the GPU can do 3D stuff
much faster and much
more easily.
It also happens, it looks like
we have a scroll bar here on
the right even though,
OK, there it is.
Yeah, so we have a scroll
bar here on the right.
This gets separately
composited as
well for various reasons.
For example, when we scroll it's
easier to have the scroll
bar as a separate layer.
So that we don't have to change
any contents of this
huge root layer, so to speak,
underneath it, as we shift
that layer up and down.
So another interesting
thing we can do
is, let's go to Inspector.
And what I'd like to do is,
you can see that basically
this text here, they're
really just
simple paragraph elements.
There's nothing special
about them.
And there's this animation going
on that is completely
unrelated to these paragraphs.
However, if I create some layer
here with a Z-index
that's positive.
And I also need to actually
make it a stacking context
just so that the render tree
recognizes it as a separate
render layer.
So I'll just make a
position relative.
So I'm not actually changing
its position.
But what you see now is suddenly
this paragraph
becomes composited.
Why is that?
Well the answer is that because
of this animation we
weren't able to assume where
this text is with respect to
the animation.
And so we have to
assume that it
might overlap the animation.
And therefore we create a
composited layer out of it.
Now, in this case, we would
judge that this layer is
really unnecessary.
And the way we could avoid that
is change the Z-index so
that it's actually underneath
this animation.
So here what I have a Z-index
of one on that paragraph, it
actually is stacked on
top of the animation.
And we have to assume
that it overlaps.
So we make it a composited
layer.
If I made a Z-index that was
underneath the animation, then
there would be no reason to
composite it because it does
not overlap.
In fact, it's underneath
the animation.
So that's example number one.
Let's see.
A few other examples.
MapsGL is a fun example.
Not only does it show off WebGL,
but it also shows off
how a compositor is smart
enough to render
stuff on top of WebGL.
So what I have here is using
the vector form of MapGL.
So this map is actually a WebGL
canvas on the page.
And these elements on top
are overlapping a
composited WebGL element.
And so they also have
to get composited.
Let's see.
Any other interesting?
Android apps is also
a fun example.
Here you can see animations in
action that actually cause
other layers to get created.
So what you see here is as I
interact, as I mouse over the
shadow, the halo around
this [? holes ?]
changes some of these highlight
elements like the
brackets that are focusing
on different
elements as I mouse over.
They animate.
And what you see is that
depending on what needs to
animate, it might actually have
a lot of things on top.
And those a lot of things on top
then also need to become
composited.
Because we can't assume that the
animation is not actually
overlapping.
We have to assume that
it might overlap.
And so this is a pitfall that,
in this case, it's actually
very reasonable.
The number of layers
is not too bad.
The animations are
very controlled.
The layer explosion disappears
after the animations are done,
which is generally
a good thing.
But it's still interesting to
note that it can accidentally
get out of hand if you're
not careful in
making your web page.
It's also interesting to note
that we have some 3D layers
here that get composited.
There's a flip card
animation here.
If you see the purple
composited
layer flipping around.
The reason that it's purple is
because in our compositor we
actually have to create a
secondary intermediate thing
where we render a bunch of
composited layers into another
intermediate surface.
That's what this purple is.
The reason we have to do that
is because we have something
like this 3D composited
layer inside of it.
But we're going to want
to do something 3D to
this outside layer.
Like a flip card animation.
And so what that requires is
that we actually have to
render a bunch of composited
layers down to an
intermediate surface.
And that's what this blue
layer actually is.
In our Chromium compositor
terminology we call that a
render surface.
If you encounter that.
Let me go back to the command
line here really quickly and
show you what it looks like
to see paper rects.
So here is poster
circle again.
Now notice that you're not
seeing any visualizations on
top of the page itself yet.
And the reason is is
because nothing is
actually being repainted.
And that's a very
wonderful thing.
That's a great place to
be on your web page as
often as you can.
If I actually select some text,
though, you can actually
see that there's this red
visualization that comes up on
top showing that, oh, actually
this is a region of the page
that needed to be repainted
at that particular frame.
And the reason it's flickering
on and off is because the
animation is actually going on
as well, at the same time.
And so the next frame is so soon
after that the paint rect
for the previous frame
disappears.
That's why it's flickering.
If you had a more static page
and you selected some text,
you would see that visualization
stick because no
other frame has been rendered
after that yet.
So that's interesting.
Maybe one last thing to show
is property change rects.
Again, show paint rects is
probably the most important,
especially to get web apps.
You want to avoid paint rects
showing up if you use that
visualization.
But in the case of property
change rects.
In the case of property
change rects, it's
actually a good thing.
And so what you're seeing here
is that well the animations
here are actually animating the
CSS transform property.
And so that property is
changing every frame.
And these rects are just a rough
visualization to show
that here the layers that
actually did need to be
redrawn even though nothing
needed to be repainted.
That's what this visualization
shows.
OK back to the slides.
So I just want to briefly go
over some of how WebCore and
Blink actually implement the
choice of how composited
layers work.
It turns out there's actually
lots of levels of abstraction
here just to get different
pieces of
software clumped together.
So at the bottom of this stack
here we sort of have the
output of the Blink side
of compositing.
The output is a tree of
composited layers.
CC is the name space for
Chromium's compositor.
So ultimately the output of
Blink deciding what's
composite is a tree of these
CC layer data structures.
For each CC layer, then, what
the compositor will do is it
will actually hook back into
Blink asking Blink, when it's
ready it will say Blink please
repeat this composited layer.
Blink then has the knowledge
of what render layers and
render objects and just how to
render what's inside of that
particular composited layer.
So just to bridge the gap
between Chromium and Blink we
have several levels of
interaction where they're
really just essentially
wrappers to CC layer.
But it's just necessary for the
fact that these are two
separate pieces of software that
are interacting with each
other and they need to
talk back and forth.
So we have this interface
called web layer.
And web layer impl is the
implementation of that.
From there on the Blink side,
then, we have graphics layer
Chromium is the actual
Chromium-specific
implementation of a
graphics layer.
And a graphics layer, then,
this is really Blink's
representation of a single
individual composited layer.
Not all of these will actually
draw things.
They may exist in the tree just
to represent a transform
or maybe a clipping region.
But the idea is that a tree of
graphics layer generally
corresponds to a tree of
Chromium compositor layers.
Basically one to one.
Not quite, but basically.
So the real interesting stuff is
actually at the top of the
stack here.
It's these top three things.
So we have graphics layer as our
Blink representation of a
composited layer.
Then we have this bridge call
render layer backing.
Render layer backing is the
bridge between render layers
and graphics layers.
So render layers, I'll just
assume that this is the input
to our problem statement
in this talk here.
But it actually came from taking
the DOM tree, computing
render tree of render objects,
that's another class in
WebCore name space is
render objects.
These render objects,
some of them become
promoted to render layers.
And so we have a tree of render
layers that some of
these render layers will have,
we would decide to be
composited.
And those composited render
layers will have
render layer backings.
The render layer backings then
will have a small chunk of
graphics layers that it puts
together to create the entire
composited layer tree.
So I know that might be a little
confusing, yet here's a
visualization that hopefully
clears up a bit of it.
On the left-hand side we start
with the render layer paint
order tree.
So the idea would be that here
where my mouse is is actually
maybe the root, the root render
view of the page.
These other layers are not
necessarily composited, but
let's say over here this next
red circle is also we chose to
make a composited layer
in the paint order.
What would happen then is these
composited layers would
have a reference, or actually
they would own a
render layer backing.
Which is represented in these
blue circles here.
By themselves the render layer
backings are not the final
output that we can actually
take in the
compositor and renderer.
Instead, the render layer
backings each manage a small
chunk of graphics layers.
And I'll show you in a second
what the purpose of some of
these graphics layers are.
But basically what happens
then is that these render
layer backings will stitch
together their chunks of
graphics layers to create the
actual graphics layer tree.
So the graphics layer tree, that
would basically be output
to the Chromium compositor, is
this tree of gray squares that
you see here.
And so it's interesting to
note that from the render
layer tree to the graphics layer
tree, it's not really a
direct correspondence.
You can't quite easily say that
this layer on the render
layer tree corresponds
to this layer in the
graphics layer tree.
What you have to say is that
this chunk of the render layer
tree corresponds to this chunk
of the graphics layer tree.
That's the way to more easily
see what's going on here.
So inside the render layer
backing, there's actually a
fairly complicated, hopefully
we can simplify this over
time, but for now the way it's
implemented, it's a fairly
complicated set of layers that
are used just for convenience.
That we can more easily handle
things like clipping or
containment of a separate
background in a foreground if
we found that while we're
computing what should be
composited, there's some cases
where it's actually reasonable
to separate the background
from the foreground.
And so that's what it is
represented here inside a
render layer backing.
Clip layers and container
layers
generally won't draw anything.
Instead their purpose is simply
to be a little bit
easier to represent something
in the tree.
So the clip layer would
basically clip its entire
subtree from the composited
layer tree's perspective.
And then, of course, once we
reach this end game here at
the bottom of the chunk of tree
here, we would have a
container that actually contains
the other render
layer children as needed.
So I basically just said
already, why do we need so
many layers?
Well scroll bars is one
I didn't mention.
It's always nice to keep scroll
bars separate so that
you don't have to change the
contents of a layer just
because you scrolled it.
All you have to do is then just
repaint the scroll bar as
things scroll around.
And then, yes, as I said clips,
background, foreground.
Grouping things together, such
as when you have contents that
would scroll you want
to group them.
Masks, reflections, these are
actually implicit if you look
at the code.
These are not actually
represented as part of this
tree, but rather each individual
layer might contain
a reference to mask or a
reference to a reflection.
So in terms of code paths, I'm
going to go over this quickly.
The slides will be
available online.
It's really something that
you just have to
read and look through.
This is more of a reference than
anything that is really
worth explaining in a talk.
But I will at least quickly say,
what we have then is we
have a paint code path which
Chromium asks Blink to paint.
And basically what happens is
each graphics layer here has
an associated paint
face with it.
And that paint phase is the way
that a render layer knows
how to paint itself.
So when we actually ask Blink,
please paint this composited
layer using your subtree of
render layers, the render
layers will then paint based on
if they contribute to that
particular graphics layer.
And the way they recognize
whether they contribute is
through this phase.
So they kind of filter
themselves out.
And they don't paint themselves
to composited
layers that they don't actually
contribute to.
So it's this phase mechanism
that couples that.
If you're asking how a render
layer paints into a graphics
layer the answer is it uses a
phase to recognize which layer
it paints into.
And then we have the code path
which actually computes what
actually gets composited.
This is the recursive algorithm
I mentioned earlier.
There's basically two
parts to this.
One is you want to determine
what gets composited.
And the second part is you
actually need to stitch
together these data structures
and initialize these data
structures.
So that second part is rebuild
compositing layer tree.
And it's worth mentioning if you
do look at this code, when
you paint, knowing what you
paint into is actually
implicitly represented
by a context.
This graphics context is
basically the 2D drawing
library that is given to a set
of render layers which was
then used to actually draw.
So in this 2D library what's
implied underneath is that you
already know what is the buffer
of pixels that you're
going to be painting into.
And so all you have to do is
use this pointer, use this
reference, this context, to
actually invoke your 2D
drawing commands.
And it will draw into
the correct buffer.
So this is the context that's
passed from the compositor to
Blink to identify your painting
into this correct
buffer of pixels.
And then as I mentioned before,
it uses the painting
phase mechanism for render
layers to identify which
composited layers
it paints into.
So these are basically the two
pieces of data that need to be
passed from the compositor to
the render layer in order to
paint correctly.
Yes and I think I'll let you
all look at these slides on
your own afterwards.
Let's talk about some of the
issues that come up with
compositing.
Compositing seems like it may
solve the world's problems,
but it actually doesn't.
And it has its own set of
problems that gets created.
Ideally, what we would like is
the compositor to be super
intelligent and it knows
what can we composite.
What would be the cost
of doing so?
What would be the memory cost,
the computation cost?
What do we gain?
And it would be able to optimize
between the trade off
of what we gain by compositing,
in particular
avoiding repainting, versus the
cost of actually computing
all that stuff in
the first place.
Realistically, that's
a very hard problem.
And it's not always clear that
there is actually an ideal
answer for various algorithms
or various policies or
heuristics we choose, we may
be trading off making some
pages better and other
pages worse.
So, in reality, what we really
do is just we composite when
we believe that we need it, or
when we really do need it.
For example, 3D transforms are
not supported unless you have
the accelerated compositor
enabled.
And once we do that and we
accept that it is what it is,
whatever we've composited
blindly, we just accept that
the overhead exists.
And we rely on ourselves as
architects of this to add
heuristics or to identify cases
where the overhead can
be reduced.
But as an algorithm itself,
the principal and the
fundamental design of the
algorithm is basically blind.
What are the overheads
of compositing?
Well there's the computational
cost of actually checking for
overlap, iterating over
all the render layers.
Where they are there can be
hundreds, even thousands on
some pages.
Most of them won't get
composited, but they all have
to be visited in order to
determine whether we might
need to composite them.
That can get pretty costly.
There's the cost of actually
managing several more layer
tree data structures.
We have the composited layer
tree structure in Chromium.
We have the graphics later
composited layer tree
structure in Blink.
We have the paint order
render layer tree.
There's actually a few extra
layer trees inside of the
Chromium compositor itself.
And mostly I think the worst
issue is that when we choose
to create a composite layer out
of a render layer, we are
saying that we intend to
allocate pixels to represent
that layer or that group of
layers, that subtree.
And that greatly increases
memory cost
for rendering a page.
There's also some issues for
just rendering in general.
In theory you should not know if
we are actually compositing
things or not.
But realistically there are
some things that you,
especially as a web developer,
might want to be aware of.
Anti-aliasing we would actually
do around the edges
of our composited layers.
But we wouldn't necessarily be
able to anti-alias as nicely
the contents inside
of a layer.
So, for example, if you had
elements with a border inside
of a composited layer and then
you maybe rotated that layer,
the edges of the composited
layer outside would look
smooth because we are able
to anti-alias those.
But the border on the inside
that renders in that layer may
not necessarily look smooth
because it's actually just
pixel data that's rendered into
the composited layer.
Another issue that comes up is
the difference between LCD
text anti-aliasing and non LCD
text anti-aliasing, which
looks a bit blurrier.
Unless we know for sure that
the composited layer is
completely opaque, we
actually cannot.
There's just some fundamental
limitations that solving them
is actually bit costly.
And it's an open problem of how
we might eventually solve
this, but we actually
cannot do LCD text
anti-aliasing in that case.
The best we can do then is
resort to the blurry text
anti-aliasiing.
And for devices that don't
have a high resolution,
switching between these two
actually becomes very
noticeable and unpleasing.
And in many cases it's not
even just the switching
between the two that would look
like the text is sort of
flickering or wiggling a little,
but also just the fact
that you might get blurry text
where you would prefer to have
very nicely anti-alias text.
A good example of this is in
menus, nav bars at the top
that you might make fixed
position, for example.
If they become composited
for some reason.
Maybe they overlap some other
composited stuff, their text
might not be able to get nice
LCD text anti-aliasing.
In theory we also want
to render at
least as fast as software.
And generally we do.
It is usually quite successful
at rendering very fast.
But there's often cases where
once a page becomes
complicated enough, especially
if we cannot benefit from
avoiding repainting.
If we still really need to
repaint layers every frame,
then compositing actually is not
going to be as beneficial.
We would have to
repaint anyway.
We would have to not only do the
repainting whether we were
in software or in composited
mode, but we would also then
with composited mode have
potentially a larger number of
layers that cost more memory.
And sometimes the bandwidth of
just drawing these layers on a
lightweight mobile GPU, for
example, can actually become
the bottleneck that maybe is
just more costly than the
painting itself in
some rare cases.
So I think that's about it.
If you have any questions I'd
be happy to taking them over
the graphics dev at chromium.org
discussion list.
My LDAP is Shawn Singh.
That's spelled S-H-A-WN
S-I-N-G-H @chromium.org.
Chromium I'm happy to receive
emails as well.
And thank you for your time.
Thank you for listening.
I hope you enjoyed it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]